okay so invincible has one of the
biggest plot twists in a comic book
property ever
the reveal that everyone's favorite
super powered dad was actually part of a
race of supremacists hell bent on making
the greatest queen tribute act ever
came out of nowhere even when he was
doing his best andrew garfield
impression
and denying everything we knew that he
was the werewolf that was definitely
appearing in spider-man 3 so sorry
going to take over the world but was he
right
and should we bow down to our veltromite
overlords in order to allow them to rule
over our tiny and pathetic race
who would be lucky to even be classed as
a pet well that's what we're going to be
discussing in this video
and i'm going to be breaking down the
pros and cons of a velcro my takeover
yay now there will be some spoilers here
in regards to the comics
so if you don't want to know what
happens to nolan after he leaves earth
then i recommend that you leave earth
your sucker
thumbs up buttons right there if you
enjoy the video and don't forget to
subscribe for breakdowns like this each
and every day
without the way welcome to the heavy
spoiler show
now let's get into whether omniman was
right or not
okay so in invincible we discovered that
the velcro mites have traveled through
the galaxy for millennia
invading planets aeons ago they decided
that they would create a utopian society
where only the best of the best of the
best sir were allowed to live
the veltromites took part in what could
be deemed a civil war
but it was more of a royal rumble that
saw 50 percent of the planet wiped out
the weak were eradicated and this left a
race of people who were classed as the
most powerful beings in the universe
because of this swift and decisive
action philtrum was left with a society
without murder or crime and every
citizen served the council and
government
as with most planets they slowly started
to run out of resources
and decided to head out into the galaxy
where they would conquer and take what
they could
upon arriving at a planet the
veldramites would take over
and for centuries they would enforce law
and order until the resources were
depleted
they did this throughout the universe
for millennia but as they started to
conquer more and more worlds
the population was spread very thin and
thus in order to pull off a full-scale
invasion
they needed a new tactic this involved
sending in trojan horses
who would appear as peaceful protectors
to the citizens of any planet
however these agents would have a secret
agenda
and would slowly dismantle the security
forces within said planet
so that the invasion would be much
easier we of course see omniman doing
this in the show
and after he takes down the guardians of
the globe and destroys several other
invading forces
he clearly leaves earth right for the
taking now throughout the show and comic
especially
nolan seems a bit gutted that his son
gets powers
i think this is because deep down he
knows his son has been drafted into a
war
in which he will have to choose his side
as we know mark ends up going against
his dad
and unlike my dad who would normally
treat me to a subway
nolan treats his son to a subway now
nolan
ends up leaving the planet as his son
gets through to him on an emotional
level
and in the comics series we learn that
after this point
mark is held up as the new voltromite
agent there even exists
certain dimensions and alternate
universes in the work where mark said
yes to his dad
and we saw as the pair took over the
planet however
sticking to the main timeline in issue
44 we are introduced to anissa
a viltromite ambassador who's here to
tell us they aren't all bad
see guys people like having buildings
dropped on their heads now she
approaches mark peacefully well aside
from threatening to kill debbie and
explains how beltram's world betterment
committee
works as a whole now they are called the
world betterment committee for a reason
that sort of hints to their overall
actions lisa tells us that though
vultromites take over planets
they actually bring so much more with
them because they've traveled through
the universe for millennia
they've learned a plethora of knowledge
that would help humanity to advance in
certain ways
under the viltromites anissa says that
they would share their technology
cure diseases and ensure that no
unsanctioned violence would happen
at all the world will become a utopia
for several centuries
free of death and crime and humanity
could live happily until
everyone forgot what it was like before
they came to earth
sure they would they would completely
harvest the planet in the end
leaving it an unhospitable wasteland
that looked like the start of 28 days
later
or any day in 2020 but humanity
we were gonna do that anyway now instead
of being doomed to war and death whilst
we inevitably destroyed ourselves
every human's life would be filled with
happiness and the wonderful wonderful
joy of christmas every day yay
we even see some of these viltrums
promises and actions in many ways when
mark is summoned by his father to come
help out on thraxa
here mark finds an insectoid planet that
nolan has decided to make his new home
the lifeforms there only live for about
nine months
and because of the time that has passed
many generations have lived and died
with him as their most prominent member
of society
sea vultromites actually age slower the
older they get
and because of omniman's lifespan he's
been elevated to be the ruler of the
entire planet
we actually see what's quite a peaceful
world and
nolan has started a new family there
it's only when the velcro might show up
to kill him for failing air that things
take a turn for the worse
but all in all it looks like a five-star
resort
and the the viltromates were probably
right to kill most of the planet now
things definitely could be better under
veldra might rule
and yeah they may be there maybe but
cons part of the video they're wrong
they're all
wrong now as good as everything seems
yeah
the viltrumites are just fascists that
are typically only open to one point of
view
theirs they hate people questioning them
and anissa even admits that they have
terrible tempers
and will quickly escalate the violence
even if they're simply questioned
everything within them is built to be
dominant when they have children their
dna
completely overrides their partners and
even with an insectoid from thraxia
nolan ends up having a humanoid looking
kid
they're used to having things their own
way and because of this think that's how
things should be
but it simply isn't the case sure they
would take over earth
and improve the facilities and
technology that we have
but in doing so they would also remove
any possibility of humanity advancing
beyond what they believe is fit for us
we have a tendency to destroy one
another but there also exists
great passion within us and a
spontaneous side that means we will
always try things differently
and push to progress the veltromites
don't have this
and there isn't really any joy in their
existence
now to the main point i think that we
know nolan isn't right
because of how he reacts to being his
own son senseless
an interesting point is that this isn't
just a fight between him being
a father it's also a fight over whether
he should do his duty or not
up until this point he hadn't questioned
veltron before
but seeing his son there who would still
care for him after all he's just put his
face through
makes him realize that the love mark has
is worth more than conquering a million
worlds
this is why nolan flies away and no he
doesn't admit it
experiencing humanity and being amongst
us made him realize there was beauty in
life beyond just subjugating a species
so that you could harvest their
resources this is the important message
behind invincible
and why nolan and the vultural mites
could never be right
they want to keep taking no matter the
cost but don't really have
anything to show for it they don't have
partners don't tend to fall in love with
one another
and their society is very much without
choice all that disagree are stamped
down
and though they have long life spans
they're devoid of any real joy or
happiness
debbie and mark managed to show nolan
the error of his ways
and why veltron was wrong he ended up
fleeing because
he knew he would be hunted and that
putting his own family before his duty
would be frowned upon but he still did
it anyway
and this is why we know beltrum is wrong
they are invaders there to stamp out
life and i tell you what mate
i'm not gonna stand for it anymore it's
time for us to get our cecil stedman on
raise arms together and say we're not
gonna take it
come on throw your best shot go on
anyway that's our video terrible ending
and now it's your time to talk
obviously i'd love to hear your opinion
on whether you think we're better off
with voltron or not
or you know if you just think this whole
video is pointless because it's never
going to happen
now as a thank you for interacting with
the video you'll be entered into a prize
show on the 30th of may
in which we're giving away three copies
of the godzilla versus kong collection
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the breakdown
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown on
how to kill omniman
if you're ever pushed into a corner we
go over the characters weaknesses
and everything you need to know when
going into a fight with him so it's
definitely worth checking out if you're
a complete loser without the way
thank you for watching this i mean paul
i'll see you next time
take care peace